um
and you said that you started your
podcast
knowing
or feeling that you were on your way out
yeah I think um
I I tiptoe around this conversation just
because I I tend not to uh because it's
my point of view right so I don't want
to go out there and just bash uh Logan
or Mike because at the end of the day
regardless I do separate myself from
them now regardless
God provided me these friends that I had
to put me on the platform that I have
now how'd you meet them how'd you meet I
met Logan at the gym and we became
friends and then we started
collaborating and through knowing Logan
he introduced me to his friends and his
opportunities so everything that I have
now even though I I
do not associate myself with them it is
given to me from them so I can't
disrespect them I just chose that it was
a time in my life where I have to draw
lines and boundaries and say okay I
gotta go do my own thing and I pray to
God that one day we could see eye to eye
so what was the first inkling because
when I was on the show you guys seemed
like glued at the hip like you were
inseparable
this is what you were gonna do yeah uh I
think we're just professionals we keep
it we keep it professional and then
sometimes uh that professional stuff
slips when emotions start arising I
don't know what you mean I think we kept
it perfect it's like rock paper like
they oh yeah during the show it wasn't
the solid when I was around
was it more of a friendship thing or a
business thing that was deteriorate
deteriorating
I couldn't say it that wasn't your uh
Wi-Fi that was my daughter
yeah
because you guys were friends before
anything else yes so that must have been
hard was it that aspect of it that
started to fall apart I think it's uh
honestly I think it just comes down to
respect I think once you stop respecting
somebody uh they could only Dance by
themselves with respect until they're
like okay I could just I could go dance
on my own I don't know was it the
religion uh it's just their point of
views you know and I
it it just it got messy and it just
started feeling like I wasn't around
people that truly cared for my best
interest and I truly just had to
respectfully walk away
and I I it's just so uncomfortable
talking about it because I don't ever
want to say anything to make it look
like I despise them I just oh okay so
you can talk about this from your
perspective and your point of view and
your feelings without putting anything
and you said you respect them yeah
you've already said that you got what
you got and you're in this business
because of them so I'm asking you the
because I I actually respect anybody who
is willing to change you know and and
what I mean by change is even changing
your you know it would be comfortable
for you to just be there or maybe
uncomfortable but what I'm saying is
to make that decision or to have that
decision made for you I don't know we'll
talk about that I made that decision 100
I I guarantee I could show you that
they've welcomed me back and I said no
okay so to make that decision would be a
really tough decision for most people
this is the most terrifying thing I've
ever done in my life my sister left her
job read uh it works for me my
girlfriend I have a whole team and I
don't mean to be opening up but I don't
spend a dollar for myself I I provide
for the team because they're providing
My Dreams by working with me and when it
got to a point where he made me choose
the well-being between my team and them
I had to sacrifice my life and and I
prayed that God would lift me so that
way I don't drop them and I could tell
you confidently within the six months
that I've been on my own it would take
me 10 years to do that on impulsive
foreign
[Music]